okay let's get into Donald Trump's
medical exam we I don't even know how to
reset the story at this point because
every day it's become even more and more
insane but I guess like to go really far
back
Donald Trump has been behaving oddly for
a year and increasingly people have been
questioning his cognitive stability his
mental health whether he might be
experiencing the early symptoms and
signs of dementia or Alzheimer's and so
Donald Trump in order to push back
against this decided to have a medical
exam last Friday dr. Ronnie Jackson
conducted the exam the exam was really
mostly a physical exam but the idea was
to be able to say Trump is fine mentally
and why not physically as well right if
you can say that he's just the best
president the most healthy president
ever why not say it so dr. Ronnie
Jackson conducted the test he has now
spoken and he says that Donald Trump
received a perfect score 30 out of 30 on
his cognitive exam and I'll tell you
more about why it's out of 30 that tells
us which test it is why was a cognitive
exam done because Donald Trump asked for
it here's a quote from dr. Ronnie
Jackson I've got to know him pretty well
and I have absolutely no concerns about
his cognitive ability or his you know
his neurological function I've found no
reason whatsoever to think the president
has any issues whatsoever with his
thought processes here's the problem
Jackson gave Trump the Montreal
cognitive assessment a common type of
dementia is front frontotemporal or
frontotemporal I'm not exactly sure how
it's pronounced dementia the mini mental
exam or the Montreal cognitive
assessment that Trump was given it
doesn't screen for that the Montreal
test is a 10-minute test on a thirty
point scale it tests short-term memory
recall you are given five nouns like if
I say television microphone five nouns
and then five minutes later you have to
repeat those not exactly a very rigorous
test for seeing whether there's
cognitive decline right you have to draw
a clock an analog clock showing a
particular time of day
and then you have to copy a drawing of a
three-dimensional cube you can be
experiencing cognitive decline where we
might say you shouldn't be president and
still be able to copy a cube off of a
piece of paper right in the Montreal
cognitive assessment you also do a short
exercise where you alternate between a
trail making task and to sound awareness
tasks and a two item verbal abstraction
task the point is these are pretty
simple tests there's an attention test
where you have to look at digits forward
and backwards and then focus on a
tapping you're then asked to repeat two
sentences immediately after hearing them
and then this this is just stunning a
lot of people have heard this and they
say trumpeters he's Bigley cognitively
with it you get six of the thirty points
just for naming the city and state where
the test is being conducted like if
Trump just said it's January 12 2018 and
I'm currently in Washington DC that's 20
percent of the score right so the point
is this tests for one specific type of
very significant cognitive decline and
it's not the kind that appears to be
happening in Trump right because the
symptoms of the type of dementia that is
speculated to maybe be happening in
Trump and maybe it's not right but we
need to be thorough and figure out what
did this test prove or disprove poor
judgment loss of empathy socially
inappropriate behavior repetitive
compulsive behavior frequent abrupt mood
changes and speech difficulties none of
that is tested by drawing a cube and
repeating five nouns right none of that
is even we can't deduce anything about
that from the Montreal cognitive
assessment now if the argument is
Trump's fine that's actually scary
because it means Trump's acting the way
he's been acting for some reason other
than dementia like he's genuinely a
[ __ ] or he has significant personality
disorders it's almost better if Trump
has been acting the way he's been acting
as president because he has dementia but
if not it's it's actually nothing that
we can determine from this test because
the Montreal
of assessment doesn't test for what
Trump is speculated to have the thing is
we're not gonna get another test now
this was the White House physician he
was Rama's doctor too while Obama was in
office yeah and I tend to trust the
results I mean there were some things
that the physician said that seemed a
little bit hacky to me right like he
said oh the president is so sharp and
articulate it looked a little bit
over-the-top to me it seemed like Harold
Bornstein language but what other
evidence we're gonna find you know
that's that's the problem which is that
most people won't ever even understand
how limited the 10-minute Montreal
cognitive assessment is and to be clear
I am NOT saying Trump definitively does
or doesn't have frontotemporal dementia
what I'm telling you
is the Montreal cognitive assessment
would it wouldn't tell us one way or the
other and that's just not being reported
on period now as a total aside I also
want to talk about the physical stuff
because it seems completely bogus what
is the unreported it's been reported
that d'enfer first of all number one
Donald Trump's heightened weight seemed
completely inaccurate on this it says
that Trump is six three and weighs 239
pounds which puts him coincidentally
just below being obese okay first of all
Trump publicly is known to be six to I
mean I get you know it's a one-inch
difference right six two and six three
but when you're cutting it so close in
terms of weight it is possibly the
difference between being obese and just
being significantly overweight but does
anyone believe Trump ways 239 if you see
a picture of Trump at six three or six
two and you see his physical body
how can anyone really think the guy
weighs 239 pounds I'm not buying it and
this is sparking the birther movement as
I have yet I love it that's a great term
do you believe Trump is 6-3 to 39 I
think me slouch right I mean maybe his
posture is just pours okay stands up
straight he could stand it 60 so six
three you believe 239 seems pretty low
to me and also I apparently has a
resting heart rate of 68 if you have a
diet exclusively of McDonald's and KFC
how do you have a resting heart rate of
68 particularly when Trump's cholesterol
has worsened he does exercise he takes
medication that medication is going to
be increased the bad cholesterol has
gone up significantly since the last
test I just don't know how it can
that even believing 6-3 to 39 which I
don't I think it's more like 6-2 to 59
but that's maybe a story for a different
day a guy who's 71 doesn't exercise it's
a terrible diet and has increased
cholesterol and as dr. Sanjay Gupta said
earlier today evidence of heart disease
how is that excellent health like I just
don't get it and I know most 71 year
olds have some degree of elevated
cholesterol half of them or so but to
say that this is a man in excellent
health just sounds a little weird to me
and his doctor said that he wants to put
him on a diet maybe lose 10 to 15 pounds
of the course of the next year good luck
but Trump's not open to exercise of
course because that would drain his
battery right yes that's referring to
his Trump once said that he believes I
want to try to represent it as he said
it he believes humans are born with some
total amount of energy that is available
to them throughout their entire lives
and that that amount of energy depletes
over time and that activities like
exercise make it deplete more quickly so
that exercise presumably is to be
avoided is that more or less the story
that yeah better so that's yeah I think
I'm almost saying it more articulately
than Trump did so listen I don't know
that this is going to go any further but
what is abundantly clear is that let me
put it a different way we now know that
President Ronald Reagan was already
suffering from Alzheimer's during his
presidency he probably would have passed
the Montreal cognitive assessment
because it is so simple basic and quick
that I don't think it tells us anything
of value discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash ree
d di t if you've been hearing about
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency and you want
to get involved maybe by a little but
you just don't know how
coin base is for you coin base is the
world's most used way to buy sell and
use Bitcoin aetherium light coin and
Bitcoin cash if you sign up through
david pakman.com slash coin base and buy
or transfer $100 worth of Bitcoin you'll
get a $10 bonus and so will we
so you'll be supporting the David Pakman
show sign up today at david pakman.com
slash coin
bass